business and education use the computer
but art is finding a place for it as
well
[Music]
the ability of computers to get creative
has come a long way
[Music]
while there's little chance of them
usurping artists anytime
soon what does this change mean in the
long term for those working in the
creative industries
and is the future of these industries
destined to be more imitation
or innovation i think the exciting role
that ai will play
is kicking us out of behaving like
machines and perhaps being more creative
as humans again
[Music]
these portraits might look like
paintings from centuries gone by
digital art created by human hands
but they're not each one
has been imagined and created by an
artificial intelligence
it's the brainchild of mario klingerman
he's leading a group of artists who are
pioneering the use of
ai in the world of visual arts
as an artist you are always in this
interplay between
accident and control so at one side you
want to have
control over your work but at the same
time
you also want interesting accidents to
happen using ai
allows me to find a good balance between
the two
this artwork is created using neural
networks
computer programs that mimic the
structure of the human brain
mario has trained the system on
thousands of portraits
from the 17th to 19th centuries
the ai learns from them and creates a
never-ending stream of unique
portraits
in the past decade the use of ai
has expanded into numerous creative
fields
and its role is continuing to grow
marcus de sotoy is a professor of
mathematics at the university of oxford
i think a lot of people think that all
that ai could possibly do
is to produce more of the same to
produce
pastiche and i think that's really
missing an opportunity because
this ai is really beginning to push the
boundaries change things and disrupt
things
and so i think we've really seen
something very special happening at this
moment
before they take over the world many
experts say they will take over your job
technological disruption is often
assumed to lead to job losses
but such anxieties are frequently
overblown
research into the impact of automation
in england
shows a relatively low risk of job
losses in several professions
including artists
for those working in creative fields ai
is more likely to emerge as a
collaborator than a competitor
i think it's going to change jobs and
that's the point so this is a new
collaborator
a new tool a bit like the arrival of the
camera
on the scene that really changed art so
i think there'll be art that will be
just the same as it ever was
but there'll be new jobs out there some
jobs will go
but for example i think there'll be
something like the data curator
the person who curates the data that the
ai will learn on
will be a very creative role in the
whole process
by working as an ever more sophisticated
collaborator
ai could also help to overturn another
stereotype
that machines can never be as creative
as humans
i think as creative so we can often end
up kind of repeating behaviors that have
worked in the past
actually behaving more like a machine
than a human so i think one of the
exciting roles that ai will play
is kicking us out of that rather
mechanistic way of thinking and perhaps
making us
more creative as humans again
[Music]
but alongside its potential to broaden
the creative palette
ai could also have some negative
consequences for the creative industries
in the world of music ai has resulted in
new tracks mimicking artists in every
conceivable genre
the world famous jazz singer ella
fitzgerald
ai technology is advanced enough to
learn from her back catalogue
to produce this
an original track in the same style
it's unlikely to become a new jazz
standard
[Music]
but it does highlight the potential the
technology holds
to copy artists on an industrial scale
[Music]
concerns about the long-term impact of
ai
are shared by musicians like holly
herndon who composes by collaborating
with one
she calls it spawn she's my ai baby
we've been teaching her how to sing how
to make music with us
polly's worried that there are no
intellectual property laws
or other regulations in place to protect
artists from ai-powered imitations
just from this conversation that we've
had today you would have enough audio
material to be able to make
a model of my speaking voice and kind of
do whatever you want with it
we simply cannot have this wholesale
taking of each other's work
and so i think we have to move past some
of our 20th century
logics around ip and the way that we
dealt with that and
and come up with a new framework for
that for the 21st century this legal
grey area was exposed last april
to be or not to be that is the question
whether it's his novel in the mind to
suffer the slings and that rules of all
trade just fortunately when the rapper
jay-z
reportedly tried and failed to have this
track
taken down from youtube
it used ai to make him appear to rap
lines of shakespeare
i like how innocent it sounds but holly
has a more optimistic vision for the
future of ai
in the creative arts one characterized
less by imitation
and more by originality so by layering
this we were able to kind of get the
the ai singing with the kind of real
world singing and instrumentation to
kind of meld together and occupy the
same
space
[Music]
ai's capacity to help humans make new
kinds of art
seems likely to have the most impact on
the creative industries
and the livelihoods of those working in
them in the years ahead
but what then how far does ai's
potential to disrupt human creativity
stretch
[Music]
i think there will come a moment when we
have to regard
the ai as a sort of independent
entity that is being creative and maybe
that's when
it has its own internal world when
perhaps a.i
becomes conscious in its own right which
i believe will happen at some point
there is an interaction that ai can have
with the art of the past which is at a
speed that we could never achieve so i
think there is some
possibility for ai to to reach
a state of uh creativity much faster
than we did as humans
[Music]
hello i'm tom standage deputy editor at
the economist
if you'd like to read more about ai and
creativity
then click on the link opposite and if
you'd like to watch more of our now
next series then click on the other link
thanks for watching
and please don't forget to subscribe